playing through ghost of tsushima it's
very apparent this story has a huge
emphasis on
honor betrayal and choice as well as the
consequences of those actions when
chosen in a given situation betrayal is
going to be the main focus for today as
it's going to be used to explain the
story of sensei ishikawa and how a
master has to deal with the betrayal of
his students and what the consequences
of these actions
are i want to put together a timeline
real quick of ishikawa's story as it's
very all over the place and some of it's
actually a lie throughout some of the
story quests so
let's start from the very beginning so
sensei ishii kao was actually
a part of a clan called clan nagao he
was very young and prideful but also a
legendary archer
so much so that one of his students
hironori nagao was inspired by him
ishikaw would train him but he only
nagao would use his skills to lead a
rebellion against the clan
and while he was slain in battle very
quickly he did manage to kill lots of
the clan's strongest warriors
there was a story spun around the island
the hero nori died fighting bandits but
that's what the clan did to save face
and not ruin the legacy that they had
built
ishikawa could not save his legacy or
reputation however
as he was the teacher of hionori so they
granted himishikawa mercy and allowed
him to live but he had to resign as
teacher but even though he resigned he
still wanted to teach his way of the
boat to people and
for it to be learned by others which is
why he took in a new student some time
later this student would be named tomae
the reason why he continued to teach the
way of the bow is that he states that
the way of the bow is my life and
without it it would feel like death and
he chose life
tomoy traveled to the dojo to study but
it was a bit of a walk as she grew up in
the umugi prefecture where her mom was
mostly part of a merchant family
tomoy before showing up to ishikawa's
dojo was as stated before in the umubi
prefecture but when she was a teenager
she would
travel to the otsuna prefecture pretty
close to where umugi was with a group of
her friends who were also thieves and
they would terrorize the villagers there
for years as stated in one of the side
quests
ishikawa soon realized that she was
fearless and very skilled at archery and
she showed up out of nowhere to with a
makeshift bow from her father and
continued to sink arrows into the target
and never
left even if asked to she still stayed
true to her thief tendencies as when she
would be practicing she would carry a
blade in her sleeve at all times and
when it was night she would hoard and
steal
food for herself ishikawa noticed these
tendencies but blew them off as once he
started to notice her skill
he intended on making her the next heir
via adopting her and making her a
samurai but once tomoy learned the
skills necessary
she ended up using this knowledge to
teach a group of assassins which ended
up paying her very well for the
teachings
tomoy just like hiro nora used
ishikawa's teaches and backstory to
exploit him and betray him
because of this betrayal he received
ishikawa handled the situation as he
would any other common murderer
he retaliated against her and attacked
her even though it was different as
tomway was a student of ishikawa's he
always states very clearly that he makes
no exception to anyone
and this is why in game ishikawa
comments on jin's ghost's reputation
saying that he does not want jin to
succumb to the ways of the ghost as he
would lose yet another student it's a
weird dynamic tomoe and ishikawa have as
to ishikaw was very quick to spill his
entire backstory and his teachings to a
gifted archer while tomoy said nothing
of her past and kept it all hidden
but now that we're up to date though we
could finally jump back to the present
and see what's going on we first meet
sensei ishikawa at his dojo at the
hiyoshi springs when we arrive
the shooting area is torn up like there
was a confrontation involved
after some investigation footprints are
found which point to a quarters and
inside is sensei ishikawa he states that
he was attacked by bandits this is one
of the many lies he'll be telling us
throughout the story
as we find out later that it was
actually his student tomawe who attacked
him jin not knowing this
at the time accompanies ishikawa to help
look for her you end up finding a
japanese quiver sometime
later and piece together the puzzle and
find out that it actually belongs to
tomoe it's at this point that ishikawa
teaches jin how to use the bow correctly
and trains him on how to achieve that
almost as if he knows his student won't
be coming back
under his wing and needs a new student
to teach the way of the beau about
jin ishikawa then make it to fort
nakayama and stick out the place to come
up with an attack
switching the fort finds more questions
than answers you find japanese arrows
specifically crafted by tomoy
a woman's kimono are found at the fort
as well it's discovered that it seemed
that she taught the mongols the way of
the bow and showed off her scale with
archery in order to survive and live
one of the survivors states that tomoe
shot his wife this is explained much
more later in the story as she did this
to simultaneously grant the prisoners a
quick death instead of a more painful
torturous one by the mongols
while also showing off her skill to the
mongols so she would not be killed in
the process
so now with the information learned at
the fort for the rest of the game
it's jin and ishikawa tracking down and
hunting tomoy
to pay for her crimes you can meet
ishikawa and the dojo once again to
continue the hunt ishikawa is worried
that jin isn't strong enough to fight
her so he'll be testing jin while also
hunting tomoy down simultaneously you
come across the lighthouse and jin ends
up scouting ahead
and while investigating the scene he
gets ambushed there isn't too many
mongols so it's not a huge
issue but once jin is done jin will then
comment about the ambush ishikawa knew
there was an ambush coming
but he states that if jyn couldn't
handle a few mongols he wouldn't be able
to handle tomoy jyn is taken aback by
this as this is war and no time for
funny tests and can relate to tomoe in
some way as to why she left him as his
methods for testing are a bit
questionable
you follow the mongol trail to a nearby
encampment where the mongols are holding
a couple captives tomoy was giving
orders to these mongols and has plans to
attack kiyoshi springs next meeting up
with ishikawa again he is next to his
dojo devising a plane to defend the
springs the villagers are worried about
their stuff being stolen and other
houses being burned
so they have no plans of leaving jin and
nishikawa sit atop the dojo and plant
together
the plan to defend the village is to
think about where archers would most
likely be set up for an attack and then
hopefully go to those positions and find
hunting parties to destroy them after
going to the designated positions jain
and ishikawa wipe out the mongol forces
and halt the attack very quickly just in
this one tale though ishikawa has lied
to us twice already
once about why he retired and the second
was about the identity of heonori
this is why i recapped this all in the
beginning of the video instead of
delving into it as we go
as there's so many different convoluted
plot points going on and lots of lying
it's a bit confused to keep track of
but still it's very obvious that he has
a tendency to lie about his past
now the mongol groups are taken care of
defending the village should be just a
little bit easier so the two meet back
at the dojo and talk about the plan a
bit more during this plan ishikawa
suggests that they let the mongols walk
in so they can catch tomoe
off guard jin immediately disagrees as
this puts the villagers lives at risk
and makes them an unnecessary sacrifice
while discussing what is really worth
the villagers or capturing tomoy an
arrow will land behind them
the mongols decided to flank an attack
behind you
the plan was for that haunting party not
to kill the two of them but to delay the
defending
of hiyoshi springs making attacking
hiyoshi springs a lot easier the two
then set a position at the bottom of the
hill just in front of hiyoshi spring so
that the only thing separating the
mongols from certain victory
is them flaming arrows are rewarded to
jin at this point and you can use it to
light the graphs on fire to wipe out
more than one at a time if you so choose
to
but once all the forces are clear tomoy
is then spotted burning the nagao banner
this is when the story about hilu nori
nagao is learned with the defending of
hiyoshi springs though tomoe then pulls
back and sets her slides on land more
north in order to establish order with
the mongols again
after arriving north it's discovered
ishikawa has gone ahead and that jin
should join the hunt when he gets there
after finding his location it's
discovered he is surrounded by mongols
and is injured once ishikawa is saved by
jin
jin menzens how he ended up getting
caught ishikawa claims it was because he
was outmaneuvered but it was mostly
because he was on the trail to finding
tomoy got distracted and then got caught
soon after just in this interaction it's
clear ishikawa has his priorities which
is fine but when it's the only thing you
think about
long enough to get distracted and almost
killed then it's a problem continuing
forage in an ishikawa ride to a nearby
camp while also delving into the
backstory of tomowe and why she left
which of course we already explained in
the intro which had to do with her being
in the umugi prefecture
leaving terrorizing camps with her band
of thieves and then moving to the other
area of the island once the two get to
camp after surveying it's clear that the
camp is clearly run by tomoy as her
signature dead samurai tiger practice
and japanese arrows are found all around
the camp
the camp also has a note of a supply
list containing targets and delivery
locations all over toyotama her plan is
to set up more training camps to train
more mongol warriors two of which of the
locations have been named which is kushi
and otsuna
the other part of the note says that she
promises the khan's archers will know
how to be masters at archery
and then also promises to deliver the
heads of jin and ishikawa
first is the kushi camp location upon
arriving to the kushi prefecture some of
the town's people are terrified of jin
this is some questionable behavior
considering jyn's accomplishments so far
it's discovered that tomawe and her
mongols have been terrorizing traders
and caravan runners along the road
and she left a note on one of the bodies
that says it's from ishikawa and jin
essentially framing the two for the
murders taking place in the prefecture
following the tracks you find an
abandoned camp with a woman tied up
when you talk to her you find out that
she was actually bait used by tomoy to
lure you in
and then once you came to rescue her she
would end up being shot
ishikawa mentions how he actually talked
to this captive woman days before this
engagement
as she mentioned that she saw a japanese
woman with a bow with mongols
he then asked her to look into it and
report back in a couple days
the intention was so that tomoy's body
would be the one at the camp and not the
captive lady
but it's clear it didn't work out that
way it's very obvious by this time when
ishikawa's character was built a very
excellent archer who is also extremely
stubborn
wants to keep his past a secret and
constantly wants to do things his way
and alone but now that the camp and
kushi prefecture is done the only camp
left is in
otsuna it's possible that destroying
this camp could lose her support with
the mongols and make it easier for her
to be tracked down without her mongol
support
so that's one of the outcomes the two
are hoping for the camp was very similar
to the one in kushi as it's also
containing very similar key points
like mongols japanese arrows and samurai
bodies for tiger practice while there
were any records of her plans with the
mongols like in kushi
there are footprints that lead to tomoy
and an eventual ambush
so while ishikawa fights jin fouls tomoe
to the musashi coast
tomoy didn't fight she actually wanted
to talk she warns jin to watch his back
and that ishikawa might attack him the
same way he did to her
and then briefly mentioning that she is
all alone possibly meaning the mongols
and khans have withdrawn their support
from her
she eventually jumps off the cliff and
has now completely disappeared assumed
to be heading even more north than she
already was
meeting up with the ishikawa at jokaku's
temple ishikawa discusses stories of his
past grievances and mistakes in teaching
jin about not letting the ghost consume
him
upon arriving at the agreed location in
eastern jokaku
it's discovered that ishikawa isn't
there you see a burned and destroyed
cart next to japanese arrows upon
arriving
shows up a woman named matsu you find
out later that this is tomoe and not a
woman named matsu but i will be using
matsu's name a couple times throughout
this part of the tale so just remember
matsu and tomoy are the same person
matsu claims that ishikawa was going to
hide in her house to find tomboy this is
coolly false as tomoy couldn't have worn
a mask 24 7.
so ishikawa must have known what her
face looks like and would automatically
know that that's her
and not matsu jin is also asked multiple
times in conversation throughout the
trip
on a few other different questions while
they've been searching for her snares to
see if she caught any food
like the story about the ghost being a
demon who is 10 foot tall
upon finding the last snare you see the
ocean tomoy comments on her
leaving tsushima island and sailing to
the mainland opening up an inn in kyoto
so she can greet all the beautiful
people of japan
while her servants rob them blind a
questionable goal but
nonetheless a reason to leave a war-torn
island once making it inside her house
jin knows that it's tomoy and then tomoe
confesses that the mongols withdrew her
support
but in order to help she will let jin
know the locations of where the mongols
will strike next
which is umugi cove she claims it's for
revenge but it's really so that she can
sneak away and sail for japan while the
two aren't looking you then meet up with
ishikawa and tell him the details and
then meet up with him again at umugi so
that you can go to a nearby hut and
discuss the plans with tomboy
the three travel to umuki cove so that
u3 can stop the attack they ambush the
remaining mongols and finish off those
to survive the initial ambush
and then after the fight tomoy is
nowhere to be seen jin and ishikawa
chase her down to the coast where they
find her on a boat leaving to the
mainland with a note next to her mask
the note reads sensei ishikawa we have
judged each other harshly but buddha
tells us that our greatest enemies can
be our best teachers i am grateful for
your teaching and for the chance to
fight by your side a final time
i have become your student and i would
have become your daughter but the way of
the bow is behind me now
what lies ahead i'm like an arrow shot
from a bow who knows where the wind will
take me
ishikawa is content with this and allows
her to leave and go to kyoto he tells
jin to promise him
not to make the same mistakes that he
did and that is the conclusion of
ishikawa's storyline
a stubborn master wanting to teach even
after what has happened in his past but
became too hell-bent on teaching his way
of the bow
and having an error in his lineage that
he couldn't see the darkness that
surrounded his student
but this experience has humbled him in
realizing that maybe there was some
error in his ways
and he keeps learning this throughout
the side quests that you do with him
these sidequests make him learn that
what he did was wrong and maybe he could
have gone about it a different way
but the past is the past and you must
learn from it as to not repeat the same
mistakes in the future
one thing i noticed actually was how
tomoe and ishikawa is very similar to
jin and shimra in terms of their
relationship with
tomoe and jin being the error in the
next samurai with ishikawa and shimra
being the
you know the lords and the kind of
father figure for them and also kind of
how this relationship and such
foreshadowed a little bit at the end of
the game
as ishikawa says that only a child
thinks his elders are perfect which is a
really nice reflection of ishikawa and
then also how that ties into the end of
the game with shimra
and the whole ending that happens
towards of course the end of the game i
just thought that was a really
interesting interaction that may have
been overlooked by a few people so i
thought to bring this up at the end of
the video because just for some food for
thought i want to thank you all for
joining me on this journey of ishikawa's
side quest of course let me know what
you guys think about the sciquest and
especially the video in the comments
below
expect another psyquest character next
week as usual i'm not sure who will be
tackling but that'll be surprised for
when the video goes up
but thank you for watching the video
today guys like the v if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new
as always like i said let me know what
you thought about the side quest
ishikawa is a character
in the video in the comments below and
take care i'll see you guys next week
for another video
[Music]
you